What's going on? Alan Dragu here and in
today's video, I'm going to be teaching
you how to make 10 grand in 3 days as a
copywriter with a step-by-step system.
Now, I'm this is not clickbait. I was
actually going to turn this into a
course I was going to sell to my email
list called Low Ticket Legend, but I
figured got the holidays around the
corner, Black Friday, and I want you to
be absolutely crushing it. So, then I
can collect a bunch of testimonials on
how much I am helping copyriters like
yourself kill it. So, there is some
selfishness to it, but at the same time,
you're going to win so big, so
tremendously from this video that I'm
going to just go ahead and jump right
in. Now, everything that I'm sharing on
my screen is going to be down in the
description below. I've got a document
to go alongside. I got a slide deck to
go alongside. Again, I already turned
this into a course that you are now
getting [music] for free. So, I already
had a bunch of stuff made. So, you can
go grab it for free. Put your email down
below and I'll send it right to you. And
this is the video that's going to walk
you through everything. So, how to crush
five figure launches with sub$50
products. Okay, so the goal is to make a
five figure launch$10,000 and above, but
I'm going to be using sub $50 products
and I'm going to tell you exactly how to
do it. But first, let me tell you a
quick story. Earlier this year, I bought
a watch. It's one of my dream watches,
actually. It's an Omega Seam Master. And
I bought that watch with [music]
templates. I launched some templates, a
low ticket product this year, a product
called Template Tycoon. I launched it to
my list and it was actually hilarious
because this product came out of
nowhere. I was just browsing around in
my notion and I found a whole bunch of
copywriting templates that I had created
for myself. tweet templates, thread
templates, uh emails, landing pages,
sales letters, all kinds of stuff that I
had put aside in my notion so that
whenever I come across creating one of
these things, I could just go straight
[music] to it and have some sort of
skeleton to start off with so I'm not
always starting from ground zero. Just
things that I like to do for myself.
Then I realized I was like, man, I got
like 300 templates in here. And so what
I did was I spent the rest of the
afternoon and a little bit of the
weekend packaging all that stuff,
writing a sales letter, putting together
the Thrive Cart and all that stuff. I
did a 3-day launch and it did well over
five figures, which was insane. Which
gave me the idea for this video of how
to make 10 grand in just 3 days cuz
that's exactly what I did. I made a
little bit over that in just 3 days
using Template Tycoon. and and then I
did it again and again and again with a
couple other low ticket products and I
said, "Wow, this is working out really,
really well." So now I came back to
dissect all those things and put them
into the course. I'm going to unpack
what this looks like because I actually
think that people are sleeping on low
ticket launches. A lot of people think
that launches like this only work in
those types of niches, the money making,
the health, kind of the scammy style
stuff. So, for this course specifically,
I'm actually going to be using the golf
niche, a niche that I'm semifamiliar
with, but one that is not highly
regarded as some bisop niche. And that's
going to be an example to show you that
this can work anywhere, anytime. So, the
first thing that you need to do for your
low ticket launch is you need to pick a
tiny problem. Problems are products. And
the biggest mistake that I see creators
and copywriters making when they launch
products like this to their list is
typically they make stuff that they want
to make as opposed to stuff people want
to buy. And so you need to reverse that
mentality. You need to find a tiny
problem within your market that you can
solve for them that they're willing to
pay [music] for, not the next cool thing
that you said, I would love to make
this. I'm going to show you exactly how
to solve this problem. So looking at the
screen, there's a couple ways to find
problems, but this is my preferred ways.
I like to go to YouTube. So we're
literally going to do it right now. I'll
go to YouTube and let's let's go to
golf, right? I'm going to type in golf
and there's going to be a bunch of guys
over here with golf channels. Okay, I'm
going to like to go Brian Bros golf,
Bryson D Shambo, The Masters. Okay, you
see a bunch of Tailor Made, Golf
Maniacs, DP World Tour. I'm just I'm
scrolling through these guys and I'm
gonna start clicking on to their
channels, Grant Horvitic Golf, and
there's a there's a couple guys that I
know like Danny Ma who put out like a
lot of good golf content. I'm going to
go to like Danny Mod's channel. Okay,
I'm going to hit videos and then I'm
going to hit popular. And what that does
is it gives me a historical data for his
best videos ever, his most popular
videos by views. And so now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to start
documenting [music]
some reoccurring themes that we got
going on here. Okay, I'm looking at his
most popular videos. I'm going to take a
pen and some paper and I'm going to
start writing down his reoccurring
themes right here. So I'm looking here,
stop topping your woods. Okay, so a lot
of people with their woods. Why golfers
don't hit 90% of the driver. Okay,
driver is a problem. Hit their driver
before hitting your driver. Do this for
five. Okay, driver is a problem. Okay.
How to hit the ball then the turf with
your irons. Okay. So, iron shots. How to
strike your irons. Driver swing. Okay.
So, I'm seeing some irons. I'm seeing
some drivers. Do this before your woods.
Best driver swing. Okay. So, it's pretty
obvious right off the rip. Just within 5
seconds, I can tell you people are
having issues with their driver. Okay.
So, this is a big issue. So, I'm going
to start taking these and I'm going to
write 10 videos down. Okay. 10 video
ideas down just from his videos. And
then I'm going to go to another channel,
right? I'm going to, you know, go to
Grant Horvat's channel, Grant Horvat
Golf, and I'm going to start seeing
[music] what he teaches, right? He's got
some stuff over here where I'm going to
start seeing his videos, and I'm going
to start seeing what he teaches, and I'm
going to start writing these things
down. So, that's going to be my
research. And then from there, you're
going to highlight the recurring themes.
Once you have 10 video ideas from 10
channels, that'll give you a 100 ideas.
And then from there, highlight the
things that you see on repeat. Which
brings us to the research example that I
want to show you. So after looking in
the golf niche, what I found was some
big recurring themes is how to stop
slicing your driver, how to hit your
iron straight and consistent, how to add
50 yards to your driver. Okay, so these
are the problems that continue to show
up time and time again, which tells me
there's a product in this [music]
because problems are products. So now I
may choose to do a little extra bonus
research which I like to do on Reddit.
So I like to go on Reddit. I'll maybe
find a nice golf subreddit and I'll
start seeing all the questions that
people are asking and I'll see if the
themes are recurring there. Is it just a
YouTube thing? Is it a Reddit thing?
Multi-platform research. So step two in
this process is we're actually going to
pick two problems out of the problems
that we found above, but we're going to
solve one for free. Okay. So picking two
problems, the key here is we want to
pick two congruent problems. The more
congruent the problems, the better your
launch is going to go. Now, let me
explain what that means. Out of these
list of things in this golf niche, okay,
we found a bunch of problems, but two of
the most congruent problems here are how
to stop slicing your driver and how to
add 50 yards to your driver. Those are
two problems that are they're not the
same problem, but they are super close
to each other because they're both
talking about the driver, how to swing
your drive. And so you solve those with
two different ways. And the reason we
want to do it is because if somebody has
the first problem, they very likely have
the second problem. So, you want to make
the leap from the first problem to the
second problem as small as possible,
which makes it significantly more likely
that they will be ripe for your low
ticket product when it comes time to buy
this, which is exactly what we're going
to do. We're going to solve problem one
as a free lead magnet. We're going to
solve it for free and we're going to
build an incredible resource to get
people onto your email list who want to
solve this problem. And then problem
number two, we are going to solve for
money. We're going to solve it with a
low ticket paid product. [music] The
more congruent these are, I cannot
stress this enough, the better your
launch will go. So, let's go ahead and
pick how to stop slicing the driver as
our free lead magnet. Okay, let's do it
together. So, I'm going to pick that.
The way that I might do a lead magnet is
through like a PDF guide or I might turn
it into a template. I might do a notion
page that I then publish online so it's
a URL. Or [music] I could do like a mini
video course where I shoot like a bunch
of iPhone videos and then I I put that
and the transcripts under it. Whatever
you can do, it doesn't matter. The idea
here is that you're putting a digital
document together that you will send
them in exchange for your in exchange
for their email. They're going to put
their email address in an autoresponder
like Kit or Gumroad or whatever. All
kinds of softwares that do this. And
once they put their email address,
they're going to get an email from you
with this free [music] document. Now,
for the sake of this lead magnet, let's
let's create a let's create a lead
magnet that says five at home exercises
to fix your driver slice within 30 days.
Something really practical, five steps,
uh a timeline of within 30 days, we're
going to shoot five short iPhone videos,
okay? One per exercise. If we're going
to do five exercise, I'm going to put it
in a notion document and I'm going to
give it away for an email address. Okay?
And once I have this excellent lead
magnet built [music] out, I'm then going
to post it wherever my golfer people
are. Okay? So, I'm going to go on
Twitter cuz I know that Twitter has a
nice golf community on there. I'm going
to post it in communities there. I'm
going to tag some of those people. I'm
going to post it on Reddit in those
subreddits. I'm going to post it in
Facebook groups where they are. I'm
gonna post it uh on Instagram where I
know they I'm gonna post it everywhere
that it's a free lead magnet. I may even
run ads to it. Sometimes you can
definitely do that, but just get it
organically out wherever they are
hanging out. And so what we're doing now
is we are building a high quality list
of leads. Okay? You can't just go out
there pompously trying to make 10 grand
trying to sell people buy my thing, buy
my thing. No, you have to first give a
ton of value. I.e. this lead magnet has
to be so good that when people say this,
they're like, "Oh my gosh, I can't
believe this wasn't a h 100red bucks. I
can't believe this wasn't 200 bucks."
Right? Because because this really
solved my problem. And so what we're
doing is once we get their email, we now
have a list of people who are super
interested in the thing that you do. Do
you see the difference? As opposed to if
we would have done something stupid
like, "Hey, let's do an AirPods giveaway
and build a huge email list," which a
lot of people do. Well, guess what? Now
you have a big email list of people who
care about AirPods and don't care a rip
about golf. So when you try and sell
your golf product, they don't buy
anything. That's the that is the key to
congruency. We're doing I solve this
problem and they're way more likely to
buy this problem. So now you don't have
random subscribers. You have high
quality leads. Do this for as long as
you can. Try and get 500, a,000, 2,000
emails on this if possible. Right? You
want to shotgun this approach on the
socials and collect as many emails as
you can. And then step three, we're
going to create our low ticket product.
This is the product that we're actually
going to sell. And the way that we do
that, we're going to follow the similar
rules to the lead magnet is we are going
to solve one very specific but painful
problem that is congruent with the first
problem we solved. Something that you
can implement quickly and will get your
person results quickly. Okay, this is
not a $200, $300, $400 course, but you
need to treat it like it is because
you're buying trust to continue buying
your stuff later. So, this isn't I'm not
just telling you how to do this one
time. I'm telling you how to do this
forever. The sweet spot when building
this product is you want to get it
somewhere in one of the top premium
zones where it's either the impulse
zone, right, where it's like 17 to 27
bucks. Like the right guy or gal is not
going to gawk at 27 bucks, right? 20
bucks. This is this is impulse, right?
Oh, you I could stop my slice for 20
bucks. Absolutely. I'm going to buy
that. Or you got the more premium like
3747. Not necessarily impulse buy, but
it's not expensive either. You don't
want to go too cheap like $9.99 or
anything like that because the income
ratio starts to drop dramatically and
you won't make nearly as much money.
[music] And you don't really want to go
above 67 bucks because then you're
really escaping low ticket territory. So
even for low ticket, it's going to be
similar as your lead mag. you're going
to want to do some kind of like
miniourse or a challenge or workbook
with video training or anything like
that. I'm going to keep it simple and
I'm going to do a mini course again.
Videos, three to five videos,
transcripts. I'm going to sexy it up
some more. I'm going to write some
transcripts under it. I'm going to make
the dock really beautiful. I'm going to
make it feel like a hundred bucks, $200
course. I'm going to make it feel very
expensive. Let's name our product. Okay,
so the first product we fix their slice.
Now, I'm going to go ahead and name it.
I'm going to call it the big stick boss.
Okay, this is seven science back secrets
and exercises to help you add 50 plus
yards to your driver [music] swing
without breaking your back. Okay, so you
see what I did there is I took my second
problem [music] which was very congruent
with my first problem. I turned it into
an actual product with actual modules
with a real promise. I'm going to price
it let's say 27 bucks. I like the
impulse buy zone. I like people I don't
even want them to think about it. That
price point has worked really well for
me. I'm going to do five to seven
modules, probably seven. Go one for each
video. I'm going to put those videos in
a notion document. I'm going to break
that out [music] into sections. I'm
going to have transcripts under. I'm
going to make it really nice, really
excellent. And I'm going to make it feel
like a $227 product, not a $27 product.
Because for me, again, I'm in this for
the long term. I want my people who buy
my thing to say, "That was some of the
best resources I've ever gotten." And
they trust me, and they will buy from me
again next time without even thinking
about it. you're going to want the same
thing. So, now that we got our product,
again, double downing on the quality,
add the scripts, professional setup,
highquality videos, put it in Gumroad,
put it in Thrive Cart, put it in Kit.
Even Kit Commerce has stuff you can,
this is, it's never been easier to sell
digital products. In fact, Gumroad is
probably the easiest. You don't have any
kind of recurring payments or anything
like that if you don't have a payw wall
already set up. So, [music] that would
be my recommendation. Otherwise, Thrive
Cart and Kit are great options. Step
four is I want you to launch your
product. Okay? We're going to focus 100%
on email marketing. That was the entire
point of us building a list of
highquality leads so that way we're not
shooting a bunch of promo posts that the
algo just shoots down trying to sell our
stuff on social media. No, we've moved
people who are seriously interested in
our products, highquality leads to an
email list. And now we are going to send
them emails uh for our launch to buy our
new product. And the way that we're
going to do that is by writing great
[music]
emails. But let's talk about the launch
window and the optimal time to be able
to do this. I like a 3 to 5 day launch
window. 3 days being kind of the
minimum, 5 days being the maximum. So 3
to 4 days sweet spot. This is where you
actually start to make that 5 figure
launch within the 3-day [music] time
frame. The reason is cuz more than 5
days really kills the urgency aspect.
And especially when you're in like a $27
to $37 impulse buy phase, somebody does
not need more than 5 days to decide
this. The only reason we're going 3 to 5
days is because people get swamped in
their inboxes and they're going to need
more than one opportunity to actually
see this email and respond to it. But
the shorter windows really maintain the
momentum of the launch, especially if
you send multiple emails a day. But
let's talk about that here in a sec.
This is what a typical launch pattern
typically looks like. Okay, so day one
is going to be all your impulse buys.
Okay, all the people who just see it and
they're like, "Oh, love it. Fantastic.
Yeah, solves my problem. 27 bucks, no
problem." [music] They swipe their card.
You're going to have a good percentage
of your sales, probably 30, 40% of your
sales are going to be on the first day.
Okay? And then the middle days, like day
two, three, four, those middle days are
going to be steady sales, but it's going
to be like lower than the first day.
Typically, these are people who are just
kind of dillydallying around. They're
not really the impulse buyers, but
they're kind of just waiting for the
deadline. But then on the final day,
like day five, you're going to have a
slew of purchases right there at the end
of the deadline. People know, oh, I
can't get it after this, or whatever it
is, because deadlines just make people
buy. They help move the momentum
forward. And here are the three ways
that you can actually make your deadline
meaningful and not just some fake
deadline. So the first way is you can do
a price increase. This is one of my
favorite things to do and I did this
with Template Tycoon is that I'm going
to launch at $27 [music] but I'm going
to double the price in 5 days or in 3
days, whatever. So you're doing an early
bird launch discount [music] where if
they don't buy it now, they're going to
have to pay double to get it later.
Psychologically, this is a huge move
because all humans love a good bargain.
My second favorite deadline is the
bonuses. When you buy X for $27, you get
Y for free. So, if you have some
back-end bonuses where, you know, you've
got some other golf courses or whatever
it is in your niche, you can tack that
on for free. In fact, one of my favorite
things to do is make your bonus as
valuable as the thing you're selling.
So, if your bonus is a legitimately $27
or more product that people have paid
for, [music] you can use that in your
email, your sales letters to sell this
thing as if you're practically getting
something for free. Genuinely, this
makes a no-brainer decision for
somebody. Oh, I'm going to pay 27 bucks
and I'm going to get this thing for
free. [music] Evens me out completely.
And the last one is one that I've only
used one time, but the one time that I
did it was my biggest launch ever. And
that is my gone forever deadline.
[music] meaning that at the end of this
5 days or whatever your launch window,
it will I will never sell this product
ever again. Now, typically I don't like
to do this because I like to keep my
digital products evergreen. I like to
sell them over time. But for whatever
reason, if you do want to do this, if
you want to do a oneandone product, I
guarantee it will be the biggest launch
as opposed to the first two methods
[music] because they know they can never
get this product ever again. Now, your
emailing frequency during those five
days, I would say days one to three,
let's keep it like one to two emails
max, depending on the relationship you
have with your email list. If you've if
they've all just joined your list, maybe
less if they've been on your list for a
long time, maybe a little bit more. And
then on the final day, you really want
to do, you know, three, four emails. You
want to get your two normal ones in and
then, you know, maybe one or two towards
the end of the day just reminding them
that the cart's about to close, which I
know everybody's going to say like, "Oh
my goodness, that's like 8 to 10 emails
in 3 4 5 days. I'm going to get so many
unsubscribes and all this stuff." Yes,
that is a-ok. Okay, you will get some
unsubscribes, but it's likely the people
that if they're not willing to buy a $27
product that is very likely going to
solve a huge problem for them, then they
are probably not serious leads for your
future communities, cohorts, digital
things, whatever else you're selling in
your niche. That that is one of the
reasons I love low ticket because it
kind of filters out the serious people
from the not serious people. Now, that
leads us to what am I going to say in
all these emails? eight to 10 emails in
in [music] three to five days. That's a
lot of emails. What am I going to say in
all these emails? Well, the thing that I
like to do is I love to tell stories
tied to the product. Okay? So, somehow
you have experienced a lot of things
that have taught you the things you know
to be able to make that product. You
should tell the stories based on the
lessons you teach in the product. You
may have a story where you were at the
golf range and you were just swinging at
the golf range and you saw this guy two
mats down from you swinging and he did
this weird movement with his leg. But
whenever he hit the ball, he hit that
thing like happy Gilmore and it the
driver was 3 350 and you were like, "Oh
my god, how is this guy hitting the ball
like that?" You walk down to the guy and
you say, "Hey dude, how are you doing
that?" And he says, "Well, I do this
thing with my left leg." And he teaches
you right on the spot. You learn how to
do it and bam, your driver goes 50 plus
yards more than it had ever gone before
and you now patent that as the lucky
left leg movement. Okay? So that's one
of the lessons in your course. Well, now
you could put that as an email. And in
the course, I'm going to teach you the
lucky left leg movement. All you got to
do is click the link below, purchase it,
and it's lesson number three. That is
exactly the type of emails you should be
writing to sell the product. How did you
solve the problems in the product? Tell
the stories behind it. Turn that into an
email. Point them to buy the product to
actually learn the thing you taught. The
last thing we want to do is now that
they've gone to your checkout page,
they've put their credit card in, and
they've purchased your $27 product, you
want to sell them something else. So
many studies show that someone who has
put their credit card in is three times
more likely to buy something else from
you. Well, since they're already in the
buyer mentality, let's go ahead and sell
them something else. I like to do this
with two ways. Bumps and upsells. Bumps
and upsells. Okay, a bump is that little
check box under your checkout counter
when they are buying your product. Like
this. Check this out. On my template
tycoon, you'll notice that when
somebody's checking out, there's a
little bump right here that you could
just add this extra product for $7 to
your cart. Well, check this out. When
you add an extra product for $7 to your
cart, let's say a hundred people check
out with your $27 low ticket product
[music] and and they add the $7 bump to
it. That would be $700
extra just off the bump. That adds up
fast. So low friction and a great way to
add some income. And the second way to
add some income to your funnel is an
upsell. Okay, so now after they hit
checkout, they add the bump instead
[music] of taking them out to a thank
you page. Hey, thank you for purchasing.
It actually takes them to an upsell page
and says, "Hey, wait, wait. Before you
finish, I've got a special offer for
you." This is when you can upsell uh
maybe a coaching call with you, a
virtual golf lesson. You can upsell
another one of your courses, a high
ticket course. One of the things I love
to do with the upsell is actually make a
one-time discount offer. So, I don't
offer discounts any other time, but this
that when you are in my upsell funnel, I
say 40% off or 50% off this course. that
this is a one-time once you hit skip
past this you will never see this offer
at this price again. So that makes it
even more limited and kind of plays into
the deadline. So you can go with that
something like that like a high ticket
course on discount. You could do like a
virtual consulting call like I said and
so let's let's get a nice chunky upsell
in there something like 200 bucks
something nice and fat so that we can
maximize our profits on the back end.
And so what now your new funnel looks
like is you have a $27 low ticket offer.
Okay, that's your main core product that
we're talking about. Then you have a $7
bump. Okay, very easy little upsell. And
then after that, you have a $200
fullblown upsell. So that means the
total funnel value that you have is
$234. All you need is four of those and
that's $1,000 right there. So four of
them, you got a,000. eight people go
through that, you got two grand. And so
it really starts to add up fast. But the
reality is most people will not get the
full funnel. You'll have some people
that do it, but that's all you need. You
need a couple people and that's a grand,
it's two grand, it's three grand. Starts
to add up and you're going to hit that
five figure launch very quickly. So to
recap, let's talk about the whole thing.
The low ticket launch formula is the
first thing we want to pick a tiny
problem. Get that YouTube, get that
Reddit research, write down your hundred
things, highlight the top 10. Boom, you
got your problems. The second thing is
we're going to solve one problem for
free. We're going to make a lead magnet
so good they're going to think they paid
cash for it. Third thing is we're going
to create a low ticket offer that is
completely congruent with the lead
magnet. Number four is we are going to
launch that low ticket offer to our
email list that we built with the lead
magnet. We're going to do a 3 to 5 day
launch. We're going to send them the
best emails they've ever read. And
number five, we're going to maximize our
funnels with bumps and upsells so that
way we can make some chunky cash and
they can solve their problems. So to
make sure that this low ticket and your
next low ticket launch goes really well,
I want you to measure a few things.
Okay? First, I want you to measure your
email list size. See how many people
opted in to your lead magnet offer. That
tells you how big the problem is you
were trying to solve. [music] Make sure
to check your unsubscribe and your open
rates during the launch itself so you
can see what kind of fatigue your list
is having from you. conversion rates.
You're going to want to convert about 2
to 5% uh across everything, your bumps,
your upselles, your main offer, and then
make sure you check your total revenue
per subscriber after the launch. That $1
and $3 per subscriber is is a [music]
good sweet spot. So, the next steps for
you, I want you to choose the niche
problem that you're going to solve
today. I want you to find the problem
you're going to turn into a lead magnet.
Do your YouTube, do your Reddit
research, 100 things, highlight the 10,
pick one, and then I want you to create
your lead magnet this week. Okay? You
have everything that you need to create
a great lead magnet. Put that lead
magnet out there. Blast it everywhere
and build your email list. While your
email list is building, go ahead and
start building your low ticket product.
Plan your launch. Write your emails. 3
to 5 days, 8 to 10 emails. Set up your
simple bump and your sexy upsell. Launch
that sucker. Take notes for what worked,
what didn't work, and then do it again.
But that's it for today. I hope this
video was helpful. And if it is, make
sure you can grab the resources for free
down in the description below. They are
yours. Remember, I was going to turn
this into a course. So, you just got
everything microcourse for free. And if
this video did help you, it would mean
the world to me if you can hit the like
and the subscribe button. Subscribe to
the channel. Tells YouTube that you want
me to create more content like this. And
leave a comment. Send me an email. Tell
me how this goes. Okay? I want to hear
how your low ticket offer goes to your
list. Ask me questions. Is there
anything that I didn't include in here?
I'm happy to help you. I appreciate it.
I hope this serves you well and we'll
chat